the great american sellout that's the
focus
of tonight's angle
during the long covid interrupted
campaign of 2020
americans heard a lot about this guy joe
from scranton
he sees the world from park avenue
i'd see it from scranton who's looking
out for the average person out there
people i grew up with in scranton that's
a lesson i've never forgotten
when i grew up surrounded by a lot of
hard-working folks
in scranton pennsylvania
sadly millions of voters took him at his
word
because they didn't know about his
nearly five decades in office pushing
all these policies
that are very pleasing to big business
and in bipartisan establishment
figures these are policies that ended up
robbing hardworking americans of their
wealth and their opportunities
biden's family meanwhile raked in the
doe trading on his name
and his political position at home and
abroad of course the media didn't care
i can't care about reporting any of this
because the media is corrupt
to blow the lid on joe would mean
blowing the lid on themselves
for their complicit silence through all
these years
despite of course they care so much
about the little people too the media
well the worst thing about all of this
is that for his entire
career and especially during the past
few years joe
put on a big show he's claiming to be
the guy
who cared so much about the middle class
there will be no government contracts
given out on my watch
that don't make all of the products here
in america millions of new high-paying
union jobs
i'm sick of the wealthy guys gaming the
system the power
to change this country is in your hands
in your hands
your hands well of course the rejoinder
to all of that was
and is so why didn't you do any of this
in the last 47 years
or at least let's say in the eight years
that you were vice president
and come on should joe actually assume
the presidency
don't expect the press to do its job at
holding him to his word
on any of these made in america promises
they know their lies they know they're
all lies and they're designed to placate
the working class and older americans
who just a few years earlier had voted
for trump
well the fact is right now biden plans
to reverse nearly
all of the president's hard-won
successes
for working-class americans most
importantly
trump's successes on trade and
immigration
today we learned that biden has stacked
his department of homeland security
transition team
with radical open borders fanatics
for instance the head of the agency
review group is orjadou
former chief counsel at the u.s
citizenship and immigration services
under obama
she currently heads an activist group
that calls for putting
11 million undocumented americans on a
path to full citizenship
and if you thought such a sweeping
change to america would just require
actual legislation passed through both
houses of congress so there could be
compromise and
and work between the parties well key
biden
allies just don't see it that way
extend the olive branch let them know
what your
programs are ask them to join and if
they don't
then let's go with the executive order i
used to say that to barack obama all the
time
and i'm saying that here
executive orders that's what he's
talking about well a blanket amnesty
would in and of itself become a magnet
for millions of additional illegals to
make the dangerous trek here
and that would guarantee that wages
would be depressed and opportunities
lost for legal immigrants
and entry-level american workers that's
how that's how it always plays out
but biden's plan for mass wage theft
goes even further than this
earlier this week cbs news got a hold of
biden's immigration plans
now aside from mass amnesty that's bad
enough here are the big goals
he's going to halt deportations
for 100 days upon taking office
and figure out then i guess how to avoid
deporting as many illegals as possible
by narrowing the scope of any
enforcement in the future
biden will also end the incredibly
successful remain
in mexico policy for those who cross our
southern border seeking
asylum now he's also going to rip up
agreements trump hashed out with
guatemala
el salvador and honduras to take in
those rejected asylum seekers
biden will raise the cap on refugees as
well
so right now we take in about 15 000
a year from all across the globe he's
going to raise it
to 125 000
annually and he's also going to
eliminate the travel restrictions on
people coming from terrorist hotbeds
that trump put into place years ago
now every one of these actions are going
to lead to a more
either a more dangerous america or lower
wages for working class americans
including as i said
immigrants and minorities who obey the
laws just want to
earn a decent wage for a hard day's work
biden's wealthy backers though they
believe that honest americans
must always sacrifice and never complain
don't you dare complain
about welcoming in more illegal
immigrants into the country
now remember big tech was livid when
donald trump put a freeze
on what are called h-1b visas back in
june
they what what trump wanted to do was
protect american tech jobs instead of
allowing a flood
of foreign tech workers into the country
but biden remember
he doesn't care about protecting
american tech workers jobs
streamlining naturalization process make
it easier for qualified green card
holders
to move through the uh his backlog
and by the way he just indicated he
ended h-1b visas
the rest of this year that will not be
in my administration
they the people on the company fees have
built this country
so massive unemployment under joe's
future lockdowns
and more people coming in for fewer jobs
that's great
but of course with joe things always get
worse
raise your hand if governor if your
government plan would provide coverage
for undocumented immigrants
[Applause]
i love the hand raises free health care
for people who break the law
and the taxes of legal workers will be
raised to pay for it all
biden's great american sellout is just
as bad by the way in the foreign policy
realm
he is a national security team that is
basically uninterested
in the whole national part of its duties
a former trump pentagon official tells
politico
biden is aiming to build an effective
bipartisan defense
department leadership team reaching out
to more
former officials who were appointed by
jim mattis
to talk about the transition and
potentially
serving now let me translate that into
plain english
basically the neocons are going to
retake control of our foreign policy
unless trump actually pulls all of our
troops out of afghanistan by the end of
the year
troops are going to be stuck there for
four more years
trump's refusal to go along with the
military-industrial complex
is why the troops love him but the top
military brass
and the defense contractors not so much
case in point jim jeffrey the outgoing
special envoy to syria
just today boasted that he and other
military leaders
flagrantly lied to the president and
misled the public
to keep boots on the ground in syria
after trump said
we're coming home now it's outrageous
and it's disgusting that career
officials
would put american soldiers in harm's
way for their own
personal goals or political views and by
the way these are goals and views that
the voters rejected when they elected
trump in 2016. they wanted out of these
wars
but not surprisingly the media
celebrated
this flagrant dereliction of duty abuse
disobedience whatever you want to call
it yet president trump
look he's still fighting for americans
today he angered biden's
campaign bundlers with an executive
order
banning u.s investment in companies
controlled by the chinese military
this current presidential vote tally
doesn't mean that america endorses
though biden's
open borders pro-war idiocy
have to understand that think about it
this way
the gop cleaned up in state legislatures
they flipped it
what at least 10 house seats didn't lose
in a single incumbency
and if he wins this upcoming runoff to
both runoffs in georgia we're going to
have a strong bulwark
against the left's extreme agenda and
tomorrow
we're going to see that america first
energy on full display
when trump supporters apparently from
across the country descend on dc to
demand accountability
and transparency about this contested
election
remember four years ago the media hailed
the women's march as
a repudiation of trump's election
so will the media provide the same type
of narrative this weekend
the resistance has a new face and this
time
they're resisting joe biden his handlers
his donors and all their efforts to sell
out america
and that's the angle